Hi, everyone.
In this lesson, we're going to take a look
at subsurface materials and parallax control
when it comes to Unreal and editing their materials.
So let's get started.
So one of the first things we're definitely
going to look at first is we're going to take a look
at our jade material that I have set up
and I have several examples
and I'll walk you through some of the aspects
of that material and what I did to build them.
Let's go and jump into Unreal and take a peek.
To get to this mat, you want to make sure to the,
or I should say this level,
you want to go to our class folder
and in our class folder, you're going to see maps
and you're going to go ahead and click on mat sub.
And that's pretty much where I landed.
I'm focusing on here, the area where I have jade
and some subsurface ice that I've built.
This scene is comprised of many things
where there's stuff that we already have in play
in our engine and sample content,
as well as some things that I've built
that I'm going to walk you through.
Here's an example of jade
and how you can set that up in your scene.
You can see when I move the light around,
the light is, the material itself is imitating
how light passes through it.
And it actually works really well.
To build this out,
let me show you some of the parameters first
of what we have.
Then we're going to take a look at it in our editor.
So you'll see the parent materials here
and you'll see that this instance has all the aspects
of what we need to do some fine tuning.
We have normals, we have metallic
and then we also have color.
So if I wanted to change the noise color, I can.
And some of that will show up with the rim
as I move these colors around
and say we go to like a pink
and you'll see a little bit of a pink highlight show up
in some aspects.
And I can even make them a little bit stronger
and hit okay.
I can completely change and craft this material
and customize it the way that I want.
And as bright or a concealer with a pink here
is as I want in our scene.
I'm going to cancel
and I'm going to hit undo in that last one too.
There we go.
Set it back the way it was.
So now we can also go in here
and mess with our normal intensity
as well as opacity edits.
In the opacity edits, I have it from center
and fall off for the Fresnel effect.
So I can go in here and change this if I need to
or lower it as needed in my scene.
You can see it kind of absorb in there.
It's basically like you're controlling light absorption.
I probably could even rename it to that
because it's simulating that.
So we have opacity surface mounts.
So I can go in and change this too.
As I lower it, you can make it look like
it's actually thinning out the material a bit more
so more lights coming through.
Or as I increase it,
you can make it look like it's a thick piece of jade
and it's not as easy to have light pass through.
Now we also have subsurface control.
I plugged in a Fresnel index.
This is the key to doing this
is you plug in a Fresnel index
into the material subsurface area
and I'll show you how to do that in a second.
And then we can control one,
the amount happening here with our subsurface
Fresnel index control,
as well as our overall thickness.
So we can brighten this up.
And remember you can adjust this any way you want.
Notice when I control the opacity
and I control the thickness at the same time
for the subsurface control,
I can really wash out the detail
and make it look like a lots of light is coming through
or I can limit it such a way
so it looks a little more flatter.
It's up to me and these items all let me to do,
allow me to do that.
So I'll do control Z a couple of times,
put it back to a neutral state
or pretty close to what we had before.
And we're gonna go ahead and jump into that parent
and take a look at that parent material.
Let's go and do that now.
Cool.
So let's go and double click on the parent material.
And I'm gonna go full screen for this.
So you can see what's going on.
Now, if you decide to load the object
like I showed you last time
where you load it via the sender or a sender block,
you may not get the updates quite exactly the same.
And that's just partially
because your lighting is not exactly the same.
It's a generic lighting
and you can change that light at any time.
Keep your finger on the L key
and left click and move around.
It's always better in my personal opinion
to test it out here
where the lighting is kind of a one-to-one
of what you want anyway.
But this is just a generic preview.
So in my scene,
one of the things I wanna point out first,
I'm gonna click on the grid.
You'll notice underneath the shading model,
I've switched this to a subsurface.
In that subsurface,
I went in here and created a series of network nodes
that allow me to have precise control.
One of them, I have noise control where I have lerp.
And what happens with the lerp,
it takes 50-50 between these two guys
and combines them in such a way
so that I can have an alpha
if I wanted to via a texture
or if I wanted to do it via a constant
or I wanted to have it as a scalar parameter.
Here, we have the amount of noise coming through.
We have a multiply and we take that to a lerp.
And then we just kind of,
I just layer the noise in such a way.
So there's noise stacking on top of noise.
And then we have control.
Now, if I wanted to,
I could do an overall control of all of these
and put another either lerp or multiply
with a scalar parameter
to be able to take care of that if I needed.
Now, if we go down low,
let's go and take a look here.
We have an opacity control using Fresnel Index in here.
So we're using that Fresnel Index to control this.
And this allows me to have a bit more finite
look and feel.
If we go in here,
let's go down to those areas or up in this case.
And you'll see we have a Fresnel Index here.
And like I showed you before,
we can make it so that the light is passing through more
or is a little more solid looking in our look and feel.
And you'll see there's also subsurface amount.
How much of that subsurface look do we want?
And as we lower this actually looks pretty cool.
And it looks like a really,
obviously the light's really bright,
but you get kind of that cool look and feel
that you can really sell that this looks like jade.
Pretty sweet.
And we also have the color for that too.
So you can really specialize this
to be something out of this world if you wanted to.
Ooh, almost like a waxy effect.
That's pretty cool.
And a yellow looks pretty great too.
So it's really up to you how you want to play these things.
But having the way that I have it set up
is one of the best ways that you can get it going.
Now down below, you'll notice there's
where the subsurface parameter pops in.
And I've activated that in such a way.
And I made it so that I have a subsurface color,
but that's multiplied with a Fresnel Index
in which we're messing with our exponents
as well as our base reflection fraction.
Reflect fraction, I should say that too many times.
And you'll see that I have a spec reflect thickness
kind of imitates that.
And the exponents kind of imitates our edge subsurface.
So if we go back into that instance,
we can see those things.
So under again, like I showed you before,
we have the edge subsurface control.
As you mess with this, we can pump that up
or lower that down and you'll see it more
in the lower numbers in here.
You see that right there, right around this pocket
between the one and the other one.
The other ones, it just kind of does it like we're in three
and you can see it subtly change,
but it mainly hits right around these lower numbers
where we can mess with that Fresnel Index control.
And again, remember, if you remember
from the foundation classes,
your Fresnel Index is based on where your angle is
on this object in the scene
and how that light, it tries to imitate that.
Like if you're looking at a pole from different angles,
that's pretty much what that's trying to do
is imitate that how that refraction occurs.
So if we go down here to a spec reflect thickness,
you'll actually have again, more control.
Like I told you, look at that.
It looks more like glass as I bump that up
and the higher I get, it really washes it out,
but it really looks like it has some thin areas in here
when it really doesn't.
So we're just faking it as we do this,
as we mess with these parameters.
And again, as you mess with it, as I lower it,
notice the limbs, the nose, parts of the ear,
based on the position of this light
are all going to have a different type of look and feel
on my statue.
So let's go and move this light a little more
and you can see the hotspots can really make it look
like, hey, that's looks like a thinner area,
but it really isn't.
So we're just again, fully in the eye with this.
And then we can customize a look if we wanted to.
Pretty great, pretty cool to be able to have that effect.
And that's simply what's going on here with this ice.
This ice has the same type of general effect,
a little bit more simplified.
If we open this up, let's pull this material over.
Let's open this up to full screen.
And you can see again,
we have a simple Fresnel index in the subsurface.
And then we also have the color.
If we want to control the color, we can do so.
And this one is not too bad,
giving us a little preview of what we have.
And again, you might want to add it into the scene
to be able to play with stuff like this.
And then we can mess with the subsurface.
And oh, look, it's yellow ice.
It's like yellow snow.
Stay away from that, that's weird.
You can see all the control that you have in place.
So I'm gonna go move this over.
And you can see that's pretty much repeating
the same thing here,
the same complexity we have with this shade we have here.
I've included some older samples
if you wanted to check them out
using the same effect with a little bit more control.
And what I mean by that
is you can really control your look and feel
if you go into these materials.
Let's look at this element instance number two,
and move this over.
Now these came from an older pack.
They don't have the groups in here
because I migrated them.
I did not build it.
You can see in here,
some subsurface color that we can control
as well as overall subsurface scale.
So this one is pretty simple overall,
but being able to control the scale can be helpful
because that allows you can see the bleeding in
of the blue in here
because this is stacked on two different types of materials.
And what I mean by that,
you'll see there's ice cave
and there's an instance for it.
So there's two elements.
If we go to the ice cave,
you can see, let's rip that one out too.
You can see the same type of effect here
using a frontal index and a different type of setup
where you're using a world alignment
so that it always gives us kind of the same effects.
And I'm able to shove things into each other
a little bit cleaner.
Now the normal you'll see doesn't have a subsurface
or I should say a world alignment,
which might be ideal in this case
so that every time I put in a new piece of ice,
the world alignment and the blending normals
might work a little bit better.
And we have samples for that.
I think there's like a canyon sample that does that.
But you can see this nonetheless,
this is really a simplistic ice material,
but you can see as I move the camera,
this comes up pretty nice.
Getting that water effect coming through
with these two different types of materials in here.
And that's pretty great.
And again, keep things pretty simple.
The normal's pretty simple in here.
And also the world alignment in here
for the noise coming through for the subsurface
blending with the color
is really giving us that extra push and pull in there.
Cool, so there's a lot you can do with this
and play with them.
You're more than welcome to grab these resources
and check them out.
Let's go ahead and in the next video,
I'm gonna talk about some subsurface profiling
and we're gonna get deeper into the parallax occlusion
and the difference between that and a bump offset.
Thanks again.